hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my youtube channel today I'm sort of
doing an unboxing but it's mostly like a
personal anecdote on the unboxing rather
than a product showcase in part because
I do not have the setup to do an
unboxing and I'm currently sitting on my
bed but I'm gonna be showing you guys
the lost collectible that I bought in
2016 it's one I've been really really
excited to get and it cost me a lot of
money this is the very large box
this says okami this doesn't mater Oh
sue do you have any guesses I will show
you the entire box in all its glory it's
very big and quite heavy so this is uh
the amount also figure from first four
figures who are one of the best makers
of statue slash collectibles in the
world and I have wanted a statue of
Amaterasu for ever I remember five years
ago I was searching on Amazon and eBay
to see if there was a figure of
Amaterasu that existed so that I could
add one to my collection because it felt
like a game that I really loved it was
missing they didn't really exist until
now from everything that I could find
so when festival Figgins announced this
one and I'm already subscribed to than
you slot on I super advertised I freaked
out pre-ordered these special edition
immediately which I am now going to open
it for you guys for the first time and
the tail goes right in the booty though
I should mention um it actually does
also have an actual butthole beauty's
are the details folks this is very heavy
also I love the pose so much here is the
base that we are going to put her on
lots of pretty flowers and this smartly
attaches um in the very top of kind of
her shoulder here I'm not gonna lift
this up because I'm terrified of
dropping it sorry it cost me over $300 I
also had a delayed shipment for some
reason the shipment to certain parts of
California was delayed so other people
were like posting about getting this and
I still didn't have mine it was killer
me okay it is done and I love it don't
you see me moving that box around
between edits is because I was trying to
figure out how exactly it lights up and
I realized it's incredibly smart one it
charges it doesn't take batteries so you
just charge it with a USB charger and I
was like how does it connect to all turn
the lights on it basically the base just
have a little button at the back of it
where you just gonna turn my light off
so you can see it better
oh my god I love it it's so great and
that's like a mirror onto this so it
doubly looks lit oh my god it's so good
in general in case you hadn't noticed
very very happy with my utter Oscar but
I also just wanted to talk about
collecting in general and why I've
decided to not do it as much you guessed
it it's because it's [ __ ] expensive I
used to be able to afford it because I
had less expenses and I was earning a
lot more money but living in San
Francisco is very expensive and it's
just as much as I am interesting
collected culture and this has been a
part of my life the several years it's
just gotten to a point in my journey
through adulthood where I just think I
can't justify it anymore and that
totally sucks but like probably I
recollect to go through this at some
point it's also I don't have that much
room so that's effective so I did cancel
an order of the king of Red Lions that I
also had from festival figures but I do
still have a couple of other things on
pre-order and I'm giving myself like an
exception I'm still going to collect
Batman figures because I've been working
on a collection of weird and really
artistically different Batman stuff that
I just love and I feel like there's not
that many Batman figures that suit the
weirdness that I'm talking about hang on
I'll show you this guy and this guy oh
that's a weird guy look at this man
what's he doing look how weird that is
orange guy that guy who looks 2d does a
[ __ ] spotting over there this guy
this guy looks like he's been attacked
by the Joker then if you zoom out you
just got this sweet Batman collection
and I should mention that is not all of
my Batman collect
I still have more in Australia that I'm
slowly figuring out how to get to the US
without breaking but it's also like when
you're young and renting obviously I'm
going to move at some point I'm not
gonna stay in this house forever and
every single time that I move there is a
chance that one of my statues is going
to break the exact same thing happened
with video games I almost had every
single 360 game I at least had every
single one that I wanted including some
that is still in that plastic because I
never got around to playing them because
I had so goddamn many and I was walking
up a pretty solid Xbox one collection
and PS full collection until I moved to
the US and now all of the games that I
have on discs just kind of an annoying
waste of space I think that I probably
would jump into collecting again if AI
was earning more money and it wasn't
just kind of dumb of me to do it and be
if I were living someone that I intended
to stay for a really long time like my
own house and in theory if I stopped
spending money on dumb [ __ ] maybe
that'll happen in the next decade or so
so that'd be great I feel like there
might be comments on this video people
being like it took you this long to
figure out that you need to know collect
stuff but i 100% maintain that for the
stuff that i am willing to spend $300 on
like this amano Sookie there is stuff
that you would buy that would be just as
expensive that I would think is
absolutely outrageous I think spending
more than $10 on a shirt is ridiculous
nonetheless cutting back is a very good
idea
it's very really hot for me please
support me through this I will need all
of your encouragement to not buy things
and now that I've said it in a YouTube
video I feel like it's like more
official and I have to stick to it again
accepting Batman figures I'm allowing
myself that one thing let me have it
okay that is it for me today you guys
for this not really an unboxing mostly
just me talking about collectibles and
stuff I will see you guys next time